good morning john this week i spent more
than a few moments being frustrated that
it was not the right time like putting
my son to sleep an hour before he thinks
it's his bedtime which resulted in of
course him sitting in the bed and saying
but dad i'm not sleepy which like of
course you're not it was frustrating and
no one liked it and thus we began our
biannual tradition of tweeting together
about how we don't like that this thing
happens can we please just stop changing
the clock and then the us senate was
like
okay like all of them a hundred percent
of the senate democrat and republican
and like whatever else we have now they
agreed yes this is silly and we don't
like it and it makes us all very sleepy
and you wouldn't like me when i'm
sleeping no this is not the full process
of a bill becoming a law but the
unanimity does indicate that it might
very well be a thing that actually
happened but john something amazing
happened the moment that 100 of the
senate was like yes we agree on this
suddenly a lot of people were mad the
disagreement that i saw was of two kinds
the first and most common was of this
sort oh so the senate can do things when
they are easy and free but they can't do
things when they are contentious and
complicated and expensive what a
terrible country look i don't want to be
mean about this but i'm a little bit
sleepy so i'm not making great decisions
if the choice was between universal
health care and not changing my clocks
twice a year i would take universal
health care but that's not the choice
the choice is should we do this easy and
free thing that everyone wants us to do
or not and if your response to
bipartisan legislation that will make
your life better is i have nonetheless
found a way to be angry about it i think
maybe the problem isn't in the congress
it might be in your chair and on to the
second thing which i was genuinely
shocked by because of course everyone
agrees that we should stop changing the
clocks but there are two ways you can do
it you can stick with standard time or
you can stick with daylight time and
congress wants to stick with daylight
time and there's a bunch of people who
want to stick with standard time and i'm
like oh my god
how have we found a way to argue about
this let's just make the change oh my
god no but just for clarity the change
that the senate just unanimously agreed
on is keeping daylight savings time all
year round which means later sunrises
and later sunset here are two of the
reasons people are mad one i don't want
my kid waiting at the bus stop in the
dark they might get kidnapped or hit by
a car and number two it's anti-science
because the society for research on
biological rhythms said that it would be
better for people to have more light in
the morning than have more light in the
evening i've looked at some of these
papers and indeed it seems that there
are some very small but detectable
differences in the health outcomes of
people who live on the far western
portions of time zones where sunrises
are later and sunsets are later but
there's also research showing that when
there's later sunsets kids get more
exercise there are fewer pedestrian
fatalities because people drive around
mostly after work rather than before
work and also maybe there's an effect on
crime but again all three of those
things the effects are really small and
when you ask people which might also be
important they say they would rather
have the extra hour of daylight in the
evening when they are more likely to you
know like use it and thus as with so
much in our society whether daylight
savings time forever or daylight savings
time never is the better solution is
unclear and complex and i have decided
to do a wildly controversial thing and
not care at all about which way we go
here's what i'll say and i think that
this is important perfect is subjective
it's different for every person and so
we are not going to get to perfect for
everyone we might get the perfect for
you but there will be people for whom
this will be imperfect but while perfect
is subjective in this case for once
better is very clear so let's stop the
war on the clocks and just do
whatever lawmakers will agree on john
i'll see you on tuesday